you heard a lot about systemic racism in
the media america is systematic
systemically racist and if you don't
agree then you're proof of the problem
it's an accusation that prevents you
from mounting a defense which leads to
actual systemic racism
in our education system as it pretends
to eradicate hate
one new york city school has asked
parents to rank their actual whiteness
from white supremacy to white
abolitionists how's that not systemic
racism
and if you disagree aren't you also
proof of the problem
meanwhile the oregon department of
education concluded that asking students
to show their work in math class
is evidence of white supremacy this
would all be laughable
if it weren't so damaging on global math
rankings america is 25th
and who's on top in reading science and
math
rhymes with china so instead of lessons
in something that matters we let
wocha dials gobble up our kids then
there's the woke teachers who've
probably never read shakespeare
demanding that they cut him from courses
because willie is a tool of white
oppression because he's white
it really is that simple we could all do
it and remember that san francisco
school board wanting to rename all those
schools like lincoln and washington to
more woke folk
we laughed but they were serious they've
delayed reopening classrooms to tackle
this priority
now that's just a few examples it's way
worse than that wokeness has become the
new curriculum
race warfare using identity politics to
give power
to a click of petty dictators it's
brainwashing
but actually washes away the brains
they're spending your tax dollars to
make your
kid dumber heck cnn can do that for free
so one i remember we were talking about
the sf school board and we just thought
like ah they're marginal they won't have
an impact
they're actually going to delay you know
talk discussing putting kids back in
class
and tackle the name change first that's
got to tick you off
yeah i don't think that's right i think
clearly the priority is out of place
there
it's about getting kids back in school
first and foremost
you know but again to me they are
marginal in some ways i don't think this
would go in most of the country
but you know to your larger point greg i
think we're a more diverse society than
ever
i think you see rising numbers of
minorities especially hispanics
asians now in american society and with
that comes
people who didn't have voice before
asking to be heard
but it also puts pressure on the
majority population white america
because i think they're asked to be more
aware of how they treat
the other people who are not white in
the society
so you know to ask them to think about
how they deal with
the other it's not i don't think racist
i just think it's a different america
and people have to be aware of it right
now there's a whole lot of
discussion about what it means to be
anti-racist
in the society and the you know in
summary it means being aggressively kind
of you know
looking forward taking a step in terms
of trying to make sure
that we all are treated equally i don't
think that's a bad thing at all
yeah but i think i i mean i think you
might be soft pedaling this a bit uh
this is a
this is more like an indoctrination
katie
if you if you disagree you're in trouble
well first i just want to say that i
don't think that the majority of white
americans see
people who are different than them as
the other i think most of them treat
them as fellow americans
and as their friends and with respect
instead of treating them as the other
looking at them differently because of
the color of their skin or where they're
from or whatever so just wanted to put
that out there first but yes there is
this indoctrination so
i know we've been talking about wanting
to reopen schools but maybe we should
keep them closed
so that the students are not engaged in
the classroom with these kinds of people
you remember at the beginning of the
pandemic and a lot of the teachers
didn't want
parents sitting in right on their kids
zoom classes
well this is why because this is what
they're teaching
in the elementary schools in their
middle schools in their high schools and
you are paying for every penny of it
which is why the teachers unions are
constantly fighting school choice
because there are alternative real
educations that they should be getting
and instead they're learning about
wokeness
yeah you know uh to katie's point dana
like if you couple this development
which has been happening
uh coming out of uh campuses with the
pandemic this seems like
an ideal time for a national rethink on
the future of education what can we do
well and if you look back through
history anytime there's been a pandemic
or a plague
there's always been some sort of big
massive change i think you're looking at
it when it comes to schools and
education
the point you made about the oregon
department of education saying that
showing your work
in math is white supremacy
we are making a rod for our own back
these kids are the future of this
country they are not going to be able to
compete
and i know that you know young people
might listen to this and think oh what a
bunch of old fuddy-duddies they don't
really understand
like believe us like we get it it's a
competitive world out there we have to
start acting like it in our schools k
through 12.
i like colleges funding colleges and all
this stuff about student debt
i feel like we do not spend any time
talking about k through 12 and we really
really are absolutely um i'm going to
try to overlook your foul language
fuddy duddies dana this is a this is a
family should i get bleeped
yes we're going to bleep you on fuddy
duddies uh jesse you're our most woke
person at fox
as you know um this can't be good
dana's right china's gonna eat our lunch
in 20 30 years that's what biden said
yeah the most offensive thing about this
whole thing greg
is the school trying to give parents
homework you're not sending me
homework you're not i'm not taking
homework
to reflect on my whiteness my blackness
whatever i'm done reflecting
i'm working okay you reflect on how you
can make my son or daughter
get into a great college so i don't have
to grease the university
with a generous donation all right if i
want to reflect on how bad my race is
i can watch cnn all day i just want to
address juan's point quickly okay
this all this stuff this is an attack on
western civilization
western civilization has contributed so
much
to the world to the american experiment
in terms of prosperity
individual rights and freedom
there's no problem with to western
civilization black voices hispanic
voices
great thinkers everywhere add it but we
don't need to
tear down western civilization like math
and shakespeare and abe lincoln to
accomplish
creating more diversity we can just add
more voices
that's not threatening to anybody
so i think for the past minute or two
i've heard nothing
that jesse says so i'm assuming it was
all good because my this thing just
happened